first off he's the ranking Democrat on
the House Intelligence Committee from
California's 28th our own congressman
Adam chef
[Applause]
all right so not only are you a great
guest in the audience loves you a little
bit like conned out but I know you bear
news because this just happened today
probably while you were in the air
flying out here from Washington Trump is
not going to release the other part of
the dueling memos right well that's
right you see last week over the
objections of the FBI in the Department
of Justice who said don't release this
as extraordinary reckless it's
misleading and omits material facts he
said I don't care it's going out that
was the newness memo this week though
the White House apparently has a
newfound admiration for the FBI release
anything that the FBI might be concerned
about the way they turn on a dime
well so what they're doing is they're
sending the memo back to the committee
the same committee whose majority
crafted the false memo to begin with
yeah because they know the chairman has
the president's back that's the White
House strategy so we're gonna sit down
with the FBI in the Department of
Justice so we did the responsible thing
we sent them our memo well before we
brought it up for a vote in the
committee we want to hear any concerns
they have about sources and methods the
problem is this and this is why we urge
Republicans not to go down this road
they wrote this deliberately misleading
memo that omitted all the important
information the reader needed to know
and when we supplied the material facts
it's like oh no we can't share the facts
because that would be disclosing too
much information how do you win on the
facts in an era where the facts don't
matter to people anymore or where you
can I said there's a couple of years ago
and publicans got mad at me I said you
know they're sheep and you can drive
them from to a different meadow so
easily and I meant by that it was only
about a year ago they love the FBI in
the Justice Department that was the
pillar of being a Republican law
enforcement and now if you look at the
polling they think they're in league
with the Liberals somehow and know this
is a conspiracy against Trump how do you
how do you fight that well it is
enormously challenging and I think of
all of the
all of the difficulties that we face in
terms of how we've gotten to where we
are politically
you have these serious issues of
campaign finance reform you've got
redistricting but among the most
difficult to deal with this the fact
that people now simply get their
information from different sources had
Fox News existed and been essentially
the state-run TV during the Nixon era
there might not have been a an
impeachment of Richard Nixon but there
is this whole echo chamber that supports
whatever the president says what I find
so astounding about the last year is how
much this deeply flawed president could
remake an entire political party in his
own image but that's what's happening
that is so quickly and and probably the
most distressing thing about that for me
is not what a poor president Trump
turned out to be which we could easily
foresee but rather
well okay we underestimated even that
but still the real shock the real shock
is how many people in Congress and in
the party would be complicit in that
there are only a few people who have
been willing to speak out Jeff Flake
among them I would have thought more of
my colleagues I was expected more I
would have expected people to defend our
institutions to defend the First
Amendment but no and what we are seeing
is the problem when you have someone who
lacks character in the Oval Office it
infects the whole of government it's
infected our committee that's what
produced this flawed memo to begin with
this was put out with a rule we have
never before used and for good reason
when you selectively declassify
intelligence when you misuse and
classified intelligence like this the
agencies stop sharing with the oversight
committees and the sources of
information stop sharing with the
intelligence community because they
can't trust the committee to responsibly
handle information that makes us less
safe this damage will be unfortunately
long-lasting but we need to get back to
the mission of our committee and that is
investigating what Russia did what the
Trump campaign did and what they may
have done in combination that's what we
need to focus on but I don't feel a
agency
I don't feel an urgency out there just
talking and walking among people about
Russia I mean obviously there are some
people who are in the Fox News bubble
and they just don't think it's real
but like Dhaka I feel an urgency about
and I think we agree on both those
issues and I think the dreamers good
should get their due but it looks like
that's something that I understand it's
more of a human issue or easier to see
but if you're gonna shut down the
government it seems like this is the
kind of thing I would shut down the
government for the fact that Russia is
meddling in our election and the
commander in chief is not fighting a
battle that he should be fighting for
America his number one duty the number
one thing we're here for the number
reason we have government is for
protection well I think most Americans
they're just trying to get by in their
daily lives they're trying to provide
for the family they're trying to make
sure they can get medical care for their
kid they're trying to make sure if
they're a dreamer that they don't get
deported to some country they've never
really seen before but we do need to be
mindful of the much bigger challenge
facing the country right now and that is
there is a systemic undermining of our
system of checks and balances brick by
brick the walls are being taken down the
wall between the White House and the
Justice Department the way we are
demeaning the press and as you say we're
suggesting that there is no such thing
as objective fact anymore the way the
administration says that a judge that
rules against this is illegitimate these
are ways in which they're doing enormous
damage to our system of government and
now tanks in the streets you know
I mean I laughed too I mean it's it's a
funny premise comedian lucky we like a
premise like that hahaha but I don't
it's not really funny the idea because
you should not get used to the look of
tanks in the streets we don't have that
look in America and when I've seen that
look anywhere else in the world it's
never been good and to me this is like
let's get them used to that tanks in the
street well look I would rather spend
our money on making sure that we are
taking care of our veterans who are
still having a hard time getting medical
care they need at the VA and that our
troops are supplied the way they should
be rather than doing something to
gratify the ego of the occupant at 600
Pennsylvania you should be quite honored
you have now gotten the nickname from
him you are little ship I'm kind of
disappointed because last year I was
sleazy Adam Schiff now I'm little Adam
show yes which is actually I think an
improvement so does that mean he likes
me more now it's it's all so confusing
but but I have to tell you you'll
appreciate this bill one of my
colleagues had a suggestion for how I
had to respond on Twitter to the
president's attack yeah which I didn't
take because it was much more bill more
than Adam Schiff yeah but I would share
it with you anywhere he said you should
write back dear mr. president when they
go low we go high go screw yourself
[Applause]
could pull that off that was it's just
not me
so when when they go low we get high
Bill Maher answer legal here now buzz me
on that but no you you actually I like
this that you and a number of other your
colleagues are now sort of like getting
in the game his game you mocked him
beautifully you said something recently
in one of your tweets about the
executive time in the morning that he
takes is what I was just talking about
he's doing its air for five hours do you
know this is a truly a presidency in
which you could say that the country
would be much safer in the morning and
all day if the president was watching
cartoons well the president is watching
cartoons
[Applause]